or you get moving hopefully you can hear
me oh thank you Robert Jonar that was
certainly an insightful panel and
discussion we so appreciate you taking
your time are today before we move
forward based on the comments I heard
from the panelists and all of you I
think it was important for me to stress
that the CAA has done so much since it
was launched in 2005 but we certainly
have ways to go and we are working as
hard with all of you to really continue
to grow to CAA to engage all the
instance over 285 put a thousand of us
around the world mom so we look for you
today to learn to teach to engage to
network and to really try and grow
because you are the leaders are sitting
Thank You CAA even stronger as we now
time for our breakout sessions the first
sessions will run from 11 to 11 45 and
they include the regional club and
affinity group programming and alumni
relations and development both which are
meeting on the first floor career
services which will be meeting on this
floor and then there will be the second
set of sessions from 12 to 12 45 at the
conclusion of the second session we
welcome you to join us for lunch on the
fourth floor where we hope you will
continue your conversation
we can sit with a long night from your
schools or from other schools take the
opportunity to network you have any
questions throughout the day there is an
information table where you register
this morning so please don't hesitate to
stop by and find out where you need to
go see you shortly